small small small small small small
small another wave of Israeli air
strikes in southern Lebanon more often
than not multiple targets are hit almost
simultaneously the Israeli Air Force is
targeting what it says are hezbollah's
military infrastructure and
Fighters Hezbollah 2 also increased the
tempo of its crossb operations using
more explosive weapons and suicide
drones
the years of relative calm along this
volatile border ended when the Lebanese
armed group opened a front against
Israel to help relieve pressure on its
Ally Hamas in Gaza 11 weeks later the
Battleground is still largely confined
to 3 to 4 km deep on each side of the
Border but despite escalating strikes
and rhetoric Israel still says it
prefers a diplomatic resolution instead
of a war to restore calm it is no secret
that there is United States pressure on
Israel not to uh expand or to spill over
the the this conflict to Lebanon in
spite of many threats of from the
Israeli political and military leaders
that they want uh to to destroy Lebanon
Hezbollah says it will not back down as
long as Israel continues to attack Gaza
no matter the cost it has already lost
more than 110 Fighters
it believes it is reducing pressure on
Hamas by overstretching the Israeli Army
and the evacuation of towns in northern
Israel is an achievement on its own and
while the armed group says it is ready
for war its strategy and its actions
appear to be calibrated in order to
avoid allout war based upon my
conversations with hasah hasah is very
keen on keeping the response measured
for a simple fact that um there's a
belief that these Israelis want to wage
this war right now when Hezbollah does
not want to enter a war based on
Israel's time the UN peacekeeping
mission in Lebanon describes the attacks
as a pattern of sporadic
escalation occasionally Israel has
struck heas sites deeper inside Lebanon
as the group responds with an
explanation of why it shows a certain
Target the Waring sides appear to be
respecting the Undeclared Rules of
Engagement in this confrontation
at least for now Z alaz
beut make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer